[Music]
on this thursday night police prepare to
make their move
[Music]
as demonstrators dig in for the third
straight week in the nation's capital
ottawa police warn action is imminent
i'm not going anywhere
i have no problem with jail the defiance
on the streets and the debate in
parliament as the battle over the
emergencies act heats up reducing
restrictions more provinces ease public
health measures as canada green lights
another covid19 vaccine the blame game
after shelling hits schools in eastern
ukraine the new warnings and details of
a potential russian attack this will
happen in the next several days plus a
gripping gold medal game as two hockey
juggernauts write the latest chapter in
their historic rivalry
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jeff semple
[Music]
this is the view from parliament hill
tonight the police presence there
growing by the hour along with fears of
a coming confrontation
good evening and thank you for joining
us 21 days since the ottawa occupation
began defiant demonstrators are digging
in despite repeated warnings from
political leaders and police the city's
interim police chief held a press
conference late today and he promised
residents that the downtown will look
much different by this weekend
the ottawa police service the rcmp and
the opp as well as numerous police
agencies in ontario and quebec are now
here in ottawa we've been bolstering our
resources developing clear plans and
preparing to take action
the action is an imminent
to those engaged in the unlawful protest
if you want to leave under your own
terms now is the time to do it
and in breaking news tonight police have
now begun arresting some of the
protesters on parliament hill our mike
armstrong is there for us on the ground
in ottawa mike what's the latest well we
did have some arrests here around
parliament hill
basically just as the weather started
going a little crazy these were officers
in large numbers these were however not
officers
in riot gear it was more of a surge a
targeted surge perhaps even
now there were some contentious moments
with the crowd as those arrests were
being made this was not unexpected by
the way when something happens here when
police make their big push protesters
will not be able to say they weren't
warned
teams of police officers were on the
streets thursday basically outreach
they've been saying for days protesters
should leave or face arrest now they're
adding to that message notices are being
posted on how to reclaim a vehicle once
it's been towed away meet the people
those messages aren't being well
received who are your supervisors what
are you guys doing
the warnings are piling up child
services is telling parents if they're
arrested they should have plans for the
care of their children
animal protection is saying if people
are in police custody too long they can
lose their pets every nail they try to
put in our coffin
we're going to put a screw in theirs
another sign things are changing is new
fencing crews putting an eight-foot
barrier in front of the senate building
and in front of parliament hill the
reason not immediately apparent to
protesters i don't understand it well
control in the protest area is about to
get tighter police say they won't be
allowing anyone downtown unless they
live or work in the area protesters they
say won't be allowed in that could lead
to confrontations there are several
protest camps or staging areas outside
the core where they've been shuttling
people back and forth we have
over a hundred checkpoints in this
secure area that we've established now
there are protesters in for the long
haul but there are also new voices this
ottawa woman brought her children
downtown despite warnings from child
services i don't feel unsafe in my own
city and the couple in this truck drove
in from peterborough thursday morning
officers are walking around they're not
doing anything right now
so far i'm proud to stand up
jerry richard came from edmonton with
four trucks four trucks he says he's
ready to lose he does expect something
to happen in the coming days absolutely
absolutely
i'm not going anywhere i'm standing tall
i'm standing proud and i'm standing free
you might end up in jail i'm good
i have no problem with jail i think it's
inevitable at this point the tension is
affecting some this was a video posted
by a protest organizer predicting her
arrest was likely close but saying
through tears she's ready and that's
okay
i am
i'm okay with that
and i want you to know that i'm not
afraid
now one of the arrests made tonight we
believe was one of the leaders not the
leader that was in that video someone
else but this was not the big push we're
still waiting for that police are still
adding to their numbers quebec
provincial police are sending officers
even vancouver police are sending more
officers
something is coming
jeff mike armstrong in ottawa tonight
thanks mike
and the expected police action in ottawa
comes just days after ontario police
successfully broke up another blockade
in windsor our sean o'shea watched that
operation unfold at the ambassador
bridge and he joins us now from the
protest in ottawa so sean given what you
just witnessed in windsor how do you
expect the police operation to go there
in ottawa
well it's going to be difficult uh and
different jeff for a few reasons one uh
the weather we're seeing right now but
in windsor you know you had trying to
get people away from a roadway that was
at the end of a bridge it wasn't in the
middle of a an urban center people were
able to come and go as they pleased um
it was much different it was much more
easy to control here you've got people
that are coming from other communities
from other parts of of ottawa and of
course that's what the police chief
talked about in this press conference
today the fact that starting now they're
going to set up a hundred checkpoints to
declare this safe zone so that people
will have to pass through these police
checkpoints provide identification or at
least give some kind of an idea of why
they're going into that area do they
live there do they work there do they
have good reason to be there the idea is
to try to cut off people from coming
into this area where we are unless they
have a real reason to do that all the
while while police try to get rid of the
trucks and the protesters who are here
right now jeff and sean we can see that
snow really coming down there now what
impact could that winter storm have on
the police enforcement
well our chief meteorologist in toronto
here at global says 30 centimeters of
snow expected just tonight and it just
started snowing jeff not that long ago
it's pretty nice day earlier so what it
means is imagine trying to tow trucks
trying to remove vehicles in an area
where the weather is bad or you got a
foot of snow that's what they're going
to have to contend with the thing is
that the people who are still here right
now jeff these are people who are
diehards many of these people have been
here for three weeks they're the most
committed of the people that are
involved in this protest and this action
they are here for the cold but this
weather is going to make it all the more
difficult the police said that they had
a lot of tow trucks available that might
be somewhat modified because of the bad
weather that we're going to face here
it's going to be quite a weekend jeff
shawn o'shea reporting from a snowy
parliament hill thanks sean
and the federal liberals are now being
pressed to justify their use of the
emergencies act in response to those
protests the prime minister insists the
move is necessary and the house will now
sit for four days before voting on the
legislation on monday night our ottawa
bureau chief marcedy stevenson reports
on how the government is using those
emergency powers
on the first day of parliamentary debate
over the government's decision to invoke
the extraordinary powers of the
emergencies act the prime minister
defended his decision as the only option
we did it because the situation
could not be dealt with under any other
law in canada
the government is increasingly painting
a picture of a hard edge inside the
protests a small but organized group of
people and entities who may be willing
to use violence who want to end all
public health restrictions and even
overthrow the federal government
something some convoy participants have
advocated for right from the start with
memorandums and letters demanding justin
trudeau be forced out of power
the government has alleged potential
coordination between these groups across
the country
speaking to global news the public
safety minister went a step further we
are starting to see more and more public
reports
that show that those individuals who
were a part of the kutz illegal blockade
also had spent some time in ottawa a
senior government source told global
news that one of the people now facing
weapons charges from the couts protests
was at the ottawa protests just days
earlier mendicino says it's not the
government's job to determine whether
protest planning could cross the line
into terrorism plotting but says he
believes security agencies are watching
closely law enforcement is gathering
intelligence and information the
conservatives say the liberals are not
being transparent about the significant
new powers including those that can
freeze and suspend finances of those
involved in the blockades the government
should not have the power to close the
bank accounts of canadians on a whim
deputy prime minister christian freeland
defended the measures as necessary it
gives me no pleasure to impose any of
these measures
in fact we do so with great sorrow
but do not doubt our determination to
act
to defend our democracy
to defend our economy
and to restore peace
freeland refused to disclose how many
bank accounts have been frozen how much
money is now in limbo how the those
accounts are actually being selected or
how the government is verifying the
identities of the account holders also
unclear whether those who donated to the
gofundme campaigns or give sand go could
now face legal consequences including
potentially their own accounts being
affected jeff a lot of unanswered
questions there thanks mercedes
and as protesters call for an end to
vaccine mandates and pandemic
restrictions omicron cases appear to be
waning and the next phase of ontario's
reopening plan is now in effect as of
today restaurants gyms and cinemas have
no capacity limits sports arenas and
theaters can operate at 50 capacity
nightclubs at 25 percent social
gatherings can have 50 people indoors
and 100 outdoors there are no limits on
organized events such as weddings if
they require proof of vaccination or if
that event is held outdoors
and in bc meanwhile bars and nightclubs
can now reopen to full capacity and
dancing is also allowed movie theaters
sports arenas and performance spaces are
back to 100 capacity though proof of
vaccination is still required weddings
and funeral receptions are also allowed
and there are no limits on household
gatherings
health canada has just approved use of a
new covid19 vaccine for people aged 18
and older novavax is the fifth shot to
receive the green light in this country
and it's the first protein-based vaccine
available here health canada says it was
90 effective in preventing symptoms in
clinical trials and 100 percent
effective at preventing serious illness
the agency recommends two doses given at
least eight weeks apart last year the
federal government struck a deal to
produce batches of that vaccine at a
facility in montreal
western warnings of a russian attack
coming up new details and escalating
violence in eastern ukraine
welcome back we're learning new details
tonight about what the white house
claims is a russian plot to invade
ukraine the new warnings come amid
reports of a dramatic spike in ceasefire
violations in eastern ukraine over the
past week the united nations is
expressing concern and urging restraint
on all sides today saw heavy shelling in
russian-speaking regions of that country
as the u.s and its allies warned that
vladimir putin is planning to use a
false flag attack to create a pretext
for military action jackson proskow
reports from washington
shelling rang out across eastern ukraine
as russian-backed forces allegedly
opened fire striking targets including a
kindergarten
the children had been whisked away just
moments before
the u.s now believes there's little
doubt of full-scale russian attack is
coming nearly half of russia's amassed
forces are within 50 kilometers of
ukraine's border my sense this will
happen within the next several days yet
u.s president joe biden said he had no
plans to call russia's vladimir putin
and in a worrying sign russia expelled
the deputy u.s ambassador from moscow
after delivering written demands that
the u.s claw back nato or face so-called
military technical measures
we don't know what will happen but what
we do know
is that russia has amassed the biggest
force we have seen in europe for decades
russia's claim to have moved troops away
from ukraine is false according to nato
instead they say an extra 7 000 troops
were added to the 150 000 already
perched and ready to strike i am here
today
not to start a war
but to prevent one at the u.n security
council the u.s secretary of state led
the international rallying cry against
war outlining how putin might carry out
an invasion by first creating a false
pretext we don't know exactly the form
it will take
it could be a fabricated so-called
terrorist bombing inside russia
the invented discovery of a mass grave
a staged drone strike against civilians
or a fake
even a real
attack using chemical weapons
russia has already claimed mass graves
exist in disputed pro-russian regions of
ukraine and putin is said to be
preparing a rare address to the russian
parliament the u.s says it believes any
russian action would target specific
groups and key sites within ukraine
including the capital kiev
all the while ukraine soldiers on
president vladimir zelinski toured the
front lines for a second straight day
walking a fine line staring down the
russian threat while trying not to get
dragged into a bloody conflict
jackson crosso global news washington
still ahead some frightening moments for
ferry passengers sailing in stormy
waters
in germany a fierce storm packing
hurricane-force winds caused extensive
damage and led to some scary moments
aboard a passenger ferry
wow the terrifying moment happened on a
river near hamburg water crashed right
through the windows as a wave washed
over the bow of the vessel
well with the looming threat of an
invasion in ukraine keeve has just
signed a new agreement with the uk and
poland the three countries will now
coordinate on cyber energy security and
countering disinformation poland's
involvement is key as nato looks to
bolster its eastern european flank in
case of wider fallout from russian
aggression our europe bureau chief
crystal gomezing is in poland tonight
with more crystal
jeff poland was named in russian demands
late last year for de-escalation around
ukraine it wanted to see multinational
nato forces leaving the country but
we've actually seen the opposite happen
nato is flexing its muscle showing
russia that it will not leave member
states vulnerable
it's business as usual on the streets of
southeastern poland but everyone knows
the concerns facing neighboring ukraine
this is quite a nervous situation in
ukraine and
she definitely was not to wear like
ukrainian shoes in this fight if russian
forces roll over parts of ukraine human
impacts will be felt right across
eastern europe
mache milchanovsky a retired polish army
captain says russia is playing a long
game looking to rebuild a sphere of
influence after ukraine and the
baltic states the next will be poland
for sure the unified response of nato
and the fact that reinforcements keep
arriving in poland demonstrates the
west's willingness to push back against
the kremlin i had a lot of
experiences with the americans in iraq
as a soldier milchanovsky took part in
two overseas missions as a teacher his
analysis is informed by hard-earned
experience this is the most important if
we force him to change the strategies
to limit their ambitions
it will be the the biggest win of the
west the wild card is vladimir putin
himself what is he willing to do
that is why we are seeing nato forces
being bolstered along the eastern
european flank weapons and financial
supports being given to ukraine
and the ongoing urgent diplomatic talks
that continue jeff crystal commencing on
the ground in poland tonight thanks
crystal
canada's golden game up next the latest
victory in a long time hockey rivalry
a heartbreaking end to a controversial
olympic games for russian figure skater
camila vallieva the 15 year old stumbled
during the free skate portion of the
women's competition landing in fourth
place she found herself at the center of
a doping scandal after it was revealed
she tested positive for a banned
substance before arriving in beijing one
of her fellow athletes competing under
the russian olympic committee flag
captured the gold
and canada added another silver medal to
its tally today freestyle skier marielle
thompson had an explosive finish in ski
cross the whistler resident was dead
last for most of the final until a late
double pass saw her earn a spot on the
podium
it is canada's 20th medal of these
olympic games 4 gold 5 silver and 11
bronze
and the latest gold medal came in
women's hockey team canada defeated
their u.s rivals three to two the two
teams have met in all but one hockey
final since it was made an olympic sport
over two decades ago eric sorenson looks
back at their remarkable rivalry
it is as repetitive and predictable a
championship as you will find in sport
canada usa women's hockey but the
olympics is about excellence and what
these two teams have achieved is an
unparalleled competitive rivalry it came
down once more to this canada superstar
marie felipe scoring and in a fiercely
fought final canada winning
pulan has scored in the last four
olympic finals drawing comparisons to
legend haley wickenheiser this one in
particular is very special everybody
was so dialed in to be able to bring
back that gold medal and i think that's
what makes it so special canada may have
an edge historically but they are bitter
rivals who make each other better
women's hockey has been played in the
last seven winter olympics canada has
now won five gold medals the united
states the other two
to truly appreciate this unrivaled
duopoly in a single sport since the
women's world hockey championships began
in 1990 canada and the us have won every
title in the 27 world and olympic finals
finishing second to each other 25 times
the olympics are obviously a massive
stage and i think we showcased in this
tournament
you know the skill and and the speed at
which we're playing the game the
canadian women's game would not be what
it is without a worthy rival and vice
versa american hillary knight calls it
the best rivalry in sports hands down
it's wonderful she says the way we've
elevated this game and continue to
elevate the sport i think that's what
separates this rivalry because it's
happened so often and you see those two
things the excellence on the ice and the
pride in their country finland sweden
and other countries love hockey too but
must do more to catch up in the women's
game it's definitely going to take nsos
stepping up and investing in their
women's programs because we see that
level investment it pays off sarah nurse
was a seven-year-old when she watched
the canadian women win their first gold
against the americans 20 years ago the
next generation is watching now young
female hockey players out there who are
probably going to put us all to shame
one day the rivalry will be waiting eric
sorenson global news toronto
congratulations and a lot to look
forward to that is global national for
this thursday i'm jeff semple tonight's
york canada is from mount washington
near courtney bc on vancouver island
there are beautiful spots all over
canada so please email us yours to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you back here again
tomorrow take care and have a great
night
[Music]
you